as i was digging around
in one of our closets i came across
some binders and i'm going to show you
these in just a second that i had when i
was at
fayetteville state university as a
matter of fact you can see on here says
faculty portfolio fayetteville state
university gregory
b sadler and i had not just one but
two of these massive binders i don't
even know
how much they they weigh and
there's a reason i had these it was in
part because
if you were at that university and this
was quite common at the time
you had to assemble a portfolio
and that's that's what this actually is
faculty portfolio
for going up for tenure or promotion
from assistant to associate professor
full professor after full professor and
tenure you'd still have like post tenure
review
and like if you wanted to go for any
sort of prizes like uh
you know teaching awards or stuff like
that you needed you needed these these
uh
binders full of stuff and this is very
old-fashioned right
but this is from 2000 well up to 2011
when i left fayetteville state
university i taught there from
2008 to 2011. there's a whole story i'm
not going to go into about how i wound
up
in north carolina in the middle of the
financial meltdown and all that sort of
stuff
suffice it to say this is all from
three years and when i left fayetteville
state university
i actually if i'd stayed there one more
year
i was ready to go for early tenure and
promotion because i
i had done so much stuff and when i say
so much stuff
for professors we usually break things
down into three categories
there's research teaching
and what they call service and research
is the things that you publish
or going to conference presentations
typically
if you're going for tenure depending on
where you are they want to see
articles and and books and things like
that fayetteville state university is a
little weird
in that they counted a book as less than
a peer-reviewed article but that's
because it was so heavily dominated by
the social sciences people and the
education people
but everything that you did if you were
smart and i learned this early on
you needed to document because if it
wasn't documented
it doesn't exist as far as all the
hoops and people and committees that you
had to jump through in order to get
a promotion or tenure and by the way at
fayetteville state university
that was seven different entities that
all of this would have to
go to and sometimes these binders full
of stuff would actually get
lost in the process it happened more
than once
i was actually arguing before i left
for the you know the idea that we should
actually
switch from all of this sort of stuff to
an electronic format and i'm sure
they've got an electronic format now
that's sort of the common thing to do
but this was the way things were done
back in the day
only you know less than 10 years ago at
so many schools
and so every time that you did a
conference presentation every time you
published an
article every time that you uh did some
sort of
talk for the community or participated
in some workshop or did did other things
like that that could count as service
anytime you advised
all of it went into that binder all of
your teaching evaluations went into that
binder your syllabi went into that
binder or binders
and i haven't actually looked inside
this for
years and years and years certainly not
since we moved here to milwaukee in 2015
so i'm kind of curious to see
what all is is in here so to begin with
i got some
some stuff that was supposed to be filed
apparently that's just kind of
shoved in there let's see what we got
here
so these are about reappointments that's
right you had to send this stuff along
for reappointments as well
and that's nice so uh these are
things there it looks like there were a
lot of different uh
people that that you know had to sign
off on me
uh getting reappointed yeah four four
different letters right one from my
chair adegoki
one from the faculty committee with
todd frobish and eric hyman is signing
off then the dean
david barlow and then the provost
so that's interesting isn't it then we
got some certificates of completion
for oh yeah this is cool so i actually
this is something i i i needed right a
while back
here's my online teaching certification
the first time that i went through a
search certification i've done it three
times now
with three different institutions uh
this one is
is from february 2011
and what was this faculty development
seminar
uh oh yeah i completed nih
uh courses so that i could do things for
uh going to to boards for that oh an
outstanding service award that's nice
i i forgot that i was on the faculty
senate apparently i did
meritorious service to them national
library week activities
i hadn't filed this i did a presentation
you can see the youtube video of it
here's some more stuff oh here it is
national library week
a presentation i did on the ethics of
anger
my latest
student evaluation so those are things i
just hadn't filed
now take a look at this so this is the
checklist that went along with this
and all of these things had to be in
there just to get
reappointed for another two year term
what else do we got here and more
letters
don't need those um
more more forms holy crap there's a lot
of stuff in here
ah here we go here's my my cv right so
that's nice to see there's that goes on
for pages and pages and pages
then we had faculty evaluations
peer evaluations i forgot about all of
that stuff we had to evaluate each other
that oh then we have the syllabi i
taught a lot of classes
and each oh my god each class i think i
taught
there's a syllabi in there then like
when i did presentations or guest
lectures so
four motivations justifications and
theories of punishment
oh no that was actually for those were
actually
four classes that i did yeah so
course redesign materials i was heavily
involved with the collegiate learning
assessment project and so we've got that
i did some
stuff there selected supporting
materials cla development as teaching
technique and strategy
i did a number of things for that
incorporating the cla into my classes
um created a four document
exercise oh no i did this with it with
i helped the art department out with
that one i forgot about
all of this sort of stuff then there's
all sorts of
things i did with the center for
excellence in teaching and learning
uh how i you know took the things that
they were teaching
and adopted them to my classes
man and i applied for like mini grants
to do that i should put all those things
into my uh
my cv if i'm smart writing intensive
classes i did writing across the
curriculum and writing intensive things
i want to skip over some of this stuff
man learning inquiry learning community
stuff
guest lectures i did for other people
the first one i did
propaganda and rhetoric origins and
histories of african-american christian
denominations and congregations i can't
even find this document i'm glad i've
got the
the slides for it here because that's a
talk i've been meaning to come back to
i used to do a lot of stuff with
religious studies and that was a black
history
week talk post-modern theory i was
already lecturing about that back then
michelle foucault technology and power
relations a small
primer for non-experts i got i got to
look at
at these these things oh and there's
even like letters from people
saying thanks for uh giving these these
guest lectures
um i did a thing on buddhist
doctrine and spirituality and art and
architecture not even sure what class
that was for
martin luther king's letter from a
birmingham jail then we got ongoing
faculty development
more certificates geez there's a lot of
these
in here uh
metaphysics colloquium e citizenship
initiative which is back in 2009 up in
detroit look so looks like everything
that i went to
that that counted as faculty development
of some sort
i i put it in there and looks like
actually look at this i i've got some
notes for myself
in here so clearly this is not
completely ready to go
faculty development seminar we had this
entire class that we
we took and uh we got a course release
for it
so that was something i did then we got
published peer-reviewed articles and
conference proceedings
so everything that i
published i made a photocopy of it
and it went in here right and that's
that's what they wanted you to do
isn't that nutty um i actually published
a lot of stuff while i was at
fayetteville state university
i'm still in book chapters and articles
man online thing
published book reviews
articles sent out to journals because
that was
important as well um
what is this stuff conference
presentations
also i actually won an award for
conference presentations
in 2009 for like the outstanding
uh faculty award yeah i did a lot of uh
presentations this is cool i actually
have like things
i'd forgotten about here's like
conference programs in there because
at fayetteville state university they
wouldn't trust that you actually had
gone to the conference
unless they saw a program from the
conference
right so like here's one that was really
fun at uh steubenville
before before franciscan university
steubenville went really downhill
the legacy of neoplatonism uh that was a
conference that i presented on anselm
and we drove up there and my colleague
richard hall came with me
philosophy born a struggle we actually
organized a conference
at fayetteville state university um
that's a africana philosophy conference
so that was pretty cool
oh yeah i went to viterbo up here in
wisconsin
conference on the cardinal virtues
presented about anselm again
grant proposals and activities i've got
all sorts of uh
grant stuff in here that i applied for
oh and i actually did get some grants i
got to put those into my cv
as well i totally forgot about that um
faculty mentors i did that as well
what do we got here this stuff at the
end oh my gosh
this this is so these are loose
documents
this is a blast from the past so
i was the editor of the it was called
journal of philosophy um
nepal and and you know they sort of
asked me out of the blue if i would help
out and i was i did work with them
for about um six years
and so here is my appointment
uh my my tenure being um
made associate editor being made
permanent after the evaluation
etc cetera um
from ubra are y'all so that is
i for totally forgot about that they
used to call me jokingly the man from
kathmandu
uh because you know i was i was editing
that journal
then we got university service and a
bunch of stuff kind of just shoved in
here
um not sure what all these things are
but university service is really like
anything that you're doing that's
helping out the university
or the community so i gave
lectures helped organize the philosophy
born a struggle conference
did a lot of work with the cla
implementing it into the
curriculum reading club i forgot about
that we had a reading club
for um incoming freshmen and we actually
used barack obama's dreams of my
father's
we tried to get michelle obama to come
you know hbcu north carolina
helped barack win the the election
they were not interested you know
there's for people who don't understand
hbcu is historically black college or
university
and there's a tier system when you hear
about them you always hear about howard
and morehouse and
maybe a few state schools and there's
like you know those are sort of like the
harvards
and then you know fayetteville state
university or elizabeth state university
or pembroke for for native american
students they're kind of at the bottom
and they don't really count as much
because there's a class system
with historically black colleges and
universities as well but
what else oh i gave workshops for fsu
faculty um
i forgot about this look at this a
workshop in teaching the humanities
medieval philosophical arguments about
god
i gave that for the
um people who are teaching humanities
classes to help them
you know with that that sort of material
um
that's cool how to use a cla i did a lot
of stuff on on that
reacting to the past i did that and
talked about how to use research-based
drama then we have service to the
college of arts and sciences
what did i do for that oh man i was
helping out the library by giving them
recommendations for books
departmental service i was on
a couple committees
helping out with that um
what is this oh i got i got uh
asked to give a report about some
malfeasance that some of my colleagues
are engaged in
and so my my chair delegated me to do
that and then it went to the dean and
the dean was like this guy writes some
good reports
he said this review of the proposal is
absolutely outstanding so that was kind
of nice to put me on the radar
for for them um
man i did a lot of a lot of stuff
um the provost wrote an
email saying i appreciate gregory
sadler's thoughtful comments
i don't even know what this was actually
about oh interdisciplinary studies
there was an argument and two
alternative proposed models for
interdisciplinary studies major
looks like i came up with that
who knew right scholarly service to the
broader academic community here's my
philosophical society of nepal
appointment letter
oh all the journals of philosophy that
that i
i did stuff in is in there i did um
you know reviewer reports that's
nice man
helped out with some other things
looks like i was on a couple other
committees
this is interesting and then what do we
have here some more
things shoved in there not even sure
what all these materials were supposed
to be for
certificate of wreck of appreciation
from the knights of columbus for
something
oh i it looks like i helped organize a
catholic literature reading group
in fayetteville gave guest lectures to
local high schools on uh
various issues in religion and supreme
court cases
and so yeah this is all a bunch of uh
i mean this is this is a long time ago
well
some of it more than a decade ago it's
hard to get this thing to close
and uh some of it as recent as 2011.
it feels like a whole different life
that i was i was living then
so you know what's the story here well
all those things are things that i did
at fayetteville state university
and then i had to gather all of this
this stuff into these binders as
evidence that i'd actually been doing
that because i was planning on going
for early tenure and promotion that
didn't end up happening i should tell
you that story as well so
many of you know that that
my wife and i have known each other
since high school
and i'm going to tell the full story in
another sadler's stories down the line
suffice it to say we we reconnected
through facebook
at the end of 2009 uh had an epistolary
relationship meaning writing
back and forth to each other before we
actually talked on the phone or even saw
each other face to face for months
fell in love with each other decided to
get married i was going through my
divorce at the time divorce
ended in june 2010
we actually got to see each other for
the first time and start spending time
together
we went to a conference in toronto she
was up in new york i was down in north
carolina
long story short we did the um
commuter couple thing for you know about
a year and then we were like screw this
man this
this sucks uh and and there's no way
that she was coming down to north
carolina where
i i'm not a southerner i didn't want to
be down there anyway and
the hudson valley in new york is is kind
of a lot like the midwest
and so we decided i would leave
fayetteville state university
where i had written the 10-year quality
enhancement plan
i was up for early tenure and promotion
i was going to be heading all sorts of
faculty development
stuff i'd actually run uh you know
university-wide assessment
and so i left all that behind came up to
new york
and started teaching at marist college
as an adjunct and then doing the youtube
video stuff and
and you know living we're living
together and i'll tell you another story
about that some other time about you
know the move and all the other
interesting things of that but this is
the story
of you know how university
work comes together in this crazy
document or a set of documents i mean
this thing must weigh
like 20 pounds i'm guessing um
uh yeah that's that's pretty much all
there is to the story there i thought
some of you might find
interesting the sort of stuff that went
into
demonstrating what you were doing at
universities and
and and tracking it and you know
we obviously don't do things like that
anymore thank goodness
because this is kind of a crazy way to
do things
you